western women who left the u.s and great
britain to join isis and slaughter
innocents
now want to return home after our
western warriors killed all of their
husbands
these poor terrorist jihadi dreamers are
just looking for a better life
and we will analyze whether or not they
should be welcomed
back in then leftist ignoramuses try to
burn down a statue of the wrong general
lee
and jesse smallitz surrenders to cops
for his hate hoax
and the mailbag so much to get to i'm
michael knowles and this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
those poor terrorist women they're just
they're just dreamers
they just want a better life how could
you you
heartless conservatives not want to let
them back in
they have kids with their terrorist
husbands who we killed because they were
in isis
they've got little kids little dreamers
other jihadi dreamers
come on how dare you we will get to all
of this we'll talk about oda
muthana and uh and shamima begum western
terrorist ladies who are trying to come
back into our country and fortunately we
have proper leadership in those
countries right now to try to keep them
out but who knows what would happen if
the left were in charge
first let's make a little bit of money
honey with we the people holsters you
know i love
we the people holsters they offer custom
made holsters all produced
in the usa they design their own
holsters in-house they don't use any
third-party molds
this means that they will be able to fit
your firearm
perfectly they have their own 3d design
team they measure every micro millimeter
of their guns to ensure the perfect fit
you can easily adjust both the can and
ride of your holster and it will fit
comfortably and securely at all times
you're able to place the holster on your
back and set the cant
and ride at which it sits for easy
access
this is a fabulous product do not
cheap out on your holster your safety
matters
your firearm matters don't cheap out on
the holster make sure that you get a
really high quality product and by the
way
we the people holsters start at just 37
bucks a piece you can get custom printed
designs thin blue line constitution camo
american flag and more coming out each
month every holster comes with a like
t every holster ships free if it's not a
perfect fit send it back for a refund
but you won't want to send it back right
now michael knowles show listeners can
go to we the people holsters dot com
slash knowles
know w-l-e-s and enter promo code
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
at checkout get 10 bucks off your first
holster that
is as low as 37 bucks and shipping is
free and you get an additional 10 bucks
off
using my promo code that's a pretty good
deal that is we the peopleholsters.com
knowles promo code knowles at checkout
for 10 bucks off
so now you had we actually talked about
this about a year or two ago
you had this influx of women
these radicalized islamic women in the
united states
in great britain throughout continental
europe who during the rise of the
islamic state
actually left to go fight not to go
fight the islamic state but to fight on
behalf of the islamic state
so now because president trump promised
we would crush isis
militarily and we have now these women
don't have a state
isis barely exists anymore if it exists
at all
now they want to come back and say
whoopsie daisy let's pretend that
nothing happened
here is a woman hoda mutana she left at
the age of 19
left alabama the good old usa moved to
syria
married an australian jihadi who died
within three months
then she married another jihadi had a
child with him who's now 18 months old
that guy got killed as well
good job western forces and now she
wants to come back to alabama here she
is
when i was 17 i
had an account on twitter and we were
all just
normal muslims speaking together and
like we were just learning off of each
other feeding off of each other
we heard the caliph caliphate was
announced and then we
we interpreted ourselves that it was
obligatory upon us to go
in november of 2014 she left her family
and friends in alabama crossing into
syria
we didn't see much but what we did see
when we did
see it we would see dead bodies in
public
you know i'd see dead bodies but they
knew that they were going to see dead
bodies because they were on these
twitter threads and in these internet
groups
that were talking about this that's why
they left
who wants to stay in boring peaceful
free just alabama
when you can move to syria and help
islamic militants
slaughter innocents which is what this
woman did and by the way it's not like
she was
eight or nine years old here was
captured brought over there she was 19
years old
when she left the united states she
helped to spread isis propaganda on
twitter
she tweeted out quote americans wake up
go on drive-bys and spill
all of their blood we have a hard time
in the west
believing that people can think this way
because we live
in a basically decadent secular liberal
society
so we have no conception of why people
look at this cute little girl oh she
what is she now 21
22 years old why she seems normal she's
talking in a normal way
we have no conception of of anyone
truly believing that people should go on
drive-bys
and spill all of the blood as this woman
said
on twitter and so we we have this
vulnerability we don't have a natural
defense against these people who are
vicious vile terrorists who want to burn
down everything that we have we want to
spill our
blood in the street her words not mine
what we want to do is just let them come
back in that's the compassionate thing
that's the nice thing to do that's the
imprudent thing to do what does this
woman hoda musana what does she think
her punishment should be for leaving the
united states and going to fight for
isis
maybe therapy lessons may be
a process that will ensure us that we'll
never do this again
jail time i don't know if that has an
effect on people
yeah jail time i don't think that's no
nobody
what effect would jail time let's not
even consider that one
how about just some nice therapy maybe
you know honestly maybe a good day at
the spa
kind of let me get some of my troubles
out of here just
relax a little bit de-stress maybe that
would help
the gulens on this girl to be able to
look an interviewer straight in the face
and say yes i called for the spilling of
american blood in the name of the
islamic state i left
and renounced my country i joined a
major international terrorist group and
helped people slaughter innocents
throughout the middle east
i think i probably just need a little
touch of therapy she does need some
therapy she also needs some prison
this is we've talked about this this is
an issue actually on the left
and the right you remember before
christmas president trump signed that
major spring the criminals out of prison
bill the first
step act and some people on the right
cheered this on
because nobody anymore has a sense of
what prison is for
this woman as she says well we don't
really know what is the effect even of
prison on people what could it possibly
do
why would we ever punish jihadi criminal
militants and enemies of the state
we shouldn't punish them we just need to
rehabilitate them this is some therapy
that's fine no the purpose of a criminal
justice system
is justice for criminals it's not
therapy
it's not rehabilitation primarily it's
not even deterrence primarily
though those are important things it is
punishment
it is retribution for a crime this woman
she says oh i'm sorry i regret it yeah i
shouldn't have done it
but she clearly doesn't have
real remorse she doesn't understand that
she has committed a crime
and she needs to accept punishment for
that crime
unfortunately we in the west don't
understand that either and i fear that
when you don't have
knuckle-dragging right-wingers like
donald trump in charge
or conservatives in charge in britain
you're going to have people say oh come
back in
i bet you if you ask this question to
the democrat primary field
should we let this poor young woman back
in this poor young woman
of the islamic faith who was just she
got caught up she swept up in something
her husband died her terrorist husband
her other husband her other terrorist
husband we just let her back in
i bet you if you ask the democrat
presidential field
all of them would favor letting this
woman come back in
maybe give her a little therapy maybe
put her in a program to rehabilitate
herself
this is a big fear because it's creeping
into the right wing and it is
infiltrating our western thought the
west
has been slowly destroying itself
committing suicide
a masochistic society and i i
see this not just as one particular
political ideology
but infecting the whole society and down
the road i totally see a world
in which we let these people come back
in in britain there's a question as to
whether
a totally unrepentant british jihadi
lady
could come back in her name is shamima
begum and she sees no reason
why the united kingdom shouldn't welcome
her back with open arms
it's kind of heartbreaking to read but
i thought it would my family made it
sound like it would be a lot easier for
me to come back to the uk
she got a letter saying she's probably
not going to be allowed back into the uk
it's heartbreaking
heartbreaking to read i mean why
her family told her it's by the way did
you hear that little line this line
hasn't been getting covered very much
her family told her it would be easier
to come back into the uk so did she have
her parents permission
to go over to syria and join the islamic
state certainly sounds that way
how is that family still permitted to
stay in the united kingdom has that
family not been summarily arrested and
deported
and sent back to whatever god forsaken
isis hellhole they apparently support
now this woman left the united kingdom
at a slightly younger age than uh
than the other one than hoda mutant this
one shamima begum left the uk at age 15
she became a poster girl for isis in
europe
women from europe who go over and join
the islamic state she married a dutch
born
or a dutch resident jihadi over there
he was later killed too because we have
done a very good job at killing these
jihadis
and now she has no remorse she
has shown no remorse i regret it because
i've it's changed me as a person it's
made me
stronger tougher you know i married my
husband i wouldn't have found someone
like him back in the uk
i had my kids you know i did have a good
time there
she had a good time you know
listen for some people having a good
time is not their idea of having a good
time
you know maybe they prefer to work or
they prefer to be productive or that
uh very few people would consider
slaughtering a slaughtering innocents
all around the middle east as their idea
of a good time that's what she calls a
good time and she says
she wouldn't have found someone like her
husband back in the united kingdom
which i'm not even sure if that's true
anymore according to
top european union terror officials the
the united kingdom is home to some 25
000 islamist extremists why rome when
you could go
find a beautiful husband at home a
beautiful jihadi terrorist husband which
is apparently what she was looking for
totally unrepentant she wouldn't have
had her kid
we shouldn't allow her or her kid to
come here into the west either
there are so many in the west
who would let these people back in we
will
analyze why in a second then we've got
to get to obviously jesse smallett
who speaking of criminal justice has
just turned himself over to the chicago
police
but first let's talk about policy genius
life insurance is one of those topics
that everyone knows
a little about but do you understand it
well enough to feel comfortable buying
it
sometimes you know when when tragedy
strikes
you find yourself uh wishing that your
loved one
had a life insurance policy and you
might want peace of mind
to make sure that your family will be
well off if tragedy strikes
policy genius is the way to get life
insurance in minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
to find the coverage you need at a price
you can afford from there
just apply online and the advisors of
policy genius will handle all the red
tape
they'll even negotiate your rate with
the insurance company no extra fees no
commission sales agents
just helpful advice and personalized
service and policy genius doesn't
just make life insurance easy whether
you're shopping for disability insurance
to protect your home homeowners
insurance or
auto insurance they can help you get
covered fast
this is it is very important to have
life i actually made sure i'm a married
guy now
i made sure to get life insurance
responsible people really should have it
so no matter how much or how little you
know about life insurance
you can find the right policy in minutes
at policygenius.com policy genius
the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance
and listen we've see we've heard from
some people who
certainly wish that their loved ones had
life insurance
just in today's episode so you should
make sure that you make the responsible
choice
you know the liberal western
motivation or inclination to accepting
back
anyone who even if you're unrepentant
even if you're unremorseful
to say no come in it's okay terrorist
lady it's look
you've been oppressed you just we
welcome you with open arms
this actually comes from a good place
this idea comes
in part from western civilization it
comes from our seven heavenly virtues
prudence justice temperance fortitude
faith hope and charity
and it explicitly comes from charity we
want to be compassionate we want to be
perfectly merciful but the trouble
creeps in
when you choose just one virtue and you
take it to its
perfect extreme to the exclusion of all
of the other virtues what is virtuous
about that
adam smith the moral philosopher and the
economic philosopher said that
mercy to the guilty is cruelty to the
innocent
that's another way of looking at it and
let's not forget that one of our
virtues one of the heavenly virtues is
prudence
to say nothing of justice
prudence is it prudent for the united
kingdom to allow 25
000 likely islamist radicals to live in
their country is that prudent
that doesn't seem prudent and prudence
is a virtue
is it just to allow someone who
dedicated herself
to slaughtering innocent people in syria
to fighting against
what is ostensibly her own country is
that just
to just let her come back in without any
any sort of
consequence whatsoever maybe a day at
the spa maybe a little therapy and then
okay we're all even
of course not it is a totally
inverted culture that would consider it
good
and just and virtuous
to take in these unrepentant terrorists
who have betrayed their countries but
we've just
totally lost our balance of the virtues
and so now when people
virtue signal they're usually vice
signaling they're usually
maybe they're signaling one virtue to
the exclusion of all the others
and because our moral discourse has been
so degraded there's there's
very little way to open their eyes to
convince them otherwise they just
don't possess the vocabulary for it i
mean you still have some people today
even on the right defending jessie
smallitt
is it smallett or smallette i don't know
i've never watched the show
i've never heard of him before this
ridiculous incident so i guess it worked
and so much as he got some publicity out
of it
jesse smallett you know he staged this
hate hoax
he pretended he sent a hate letter to
himself when that didn't get enough
attention
he paid these two nigerian buddies of
his to come attack him and pretend to be
white racists
then he went on television crying
indicting half of the country as awful
racists
indicting the whole country is
hopelessly bigoted and then he got found
out
i even in the last few days have urged
caution on jumping to conclusions now it
seems the conclusion has been reached
here is the chicago police department
superintendent eddie johnson
talking about their findings now that
they've finally booked
jesse smallett for a false police report
and hate hoax
how can an individual who's been
embraced by the city of chicago
turn around and slap everyone in this
city
in the face by making these false shock
claims
bogus police reports cause real harm
of course they do they cause real harm
there were some people you know i really
like seth mandel so i don't want to
attack him i don't want to
criticize him too much but he sent out
an absurd
tweet the other day he said you know ju
he's a right-winger i mean he's certain
firmly ensconced on the right he says i
just think
that jesse smiled it's clear he's got a
lot of
psychological problems and he's just
maybe we should go easy on him maybe
come on let's not be so harsh actually
even his wife bethany who's been on my
show
called him out for this and said no
sorry seth
not no way pal and a lot of people on
the right just got ben came out said
absolutely not you've got this one wrong
it comes from a good place to say oh
let's be the bigger person i under it
comes from genuine empathy by the way
which the right has in far greater
abundance than the left has
the left is not terribly empathetic they
are saying stone these those covington
kids
tar and feather them they're awful
we need a coup d'etat to take trump out
i mean the left wing is
vicious without any sense of compassion
or empathy the right has a lot of
empathy why
because studies show that the right
understands the left better than the
left understands the right
uh and i do have empathy for jesse
smallett i actually i don't have empathy
for him
as a matter of politics i have empathy
for him as a sometime actor
it's real tough out there for actors and
you've gotta
even when if you can get a hit for a
little while it's not too long before
you're in obscurity
and he's feeling that he might get
written off the show he said he wasn't
happy with the amount of money he was
being paid
being an actor is a tough life i have a
lot of empathy for him
however we cannot go easy on this guy we
cannot let
him get off the hook for this we cannot
let him avoid prison
we cannot let him keep his career why
because in this case mercy to the guilty
is cruelty to the innocent
and mercy to the guilty and the jesse
smollett case
is cruelty to real victims
of real racially motivated crimes
or sexually motivated crimes or whatever
the real victims of
these crimes will now be looked on with
skepticism
that's unavoidable and
and it's right i mean there's no way
around that it's inescapable
you can't put the genie back in the
bottle actions have consequences
jesse smallett's actions have
consequences
this is why crimes once they're revealed
must be punished
because let's say that we don't punish
jesse smaller let's say we're really
just
all compassion all mercy no sense of
justice no sense of prudence well what
does that do
it gives everybody license to
fake their own hate crime to try to
steal for themselves the social currency
of victimhood
and what it what else does it mean it
means that rational people
are no longer going to trust people who
claim to have been attacked
even if they really have they they just
won't believe it anymore
if there is no punishment this will
create a perverse incentive
and the hoaxes will multiply they will
multiply
to no end and the victims will not be
treated seriously
they won't be taken seriously that's
just reality
and we can lament that i think
conservatives are uncomfortable with
that even
the left is certainly uncomfortable with
that we don't want we want to say oh
gosh we're all fallen we're all broken
we should have just total mercy total
compassion
well that's fine at a personal level
that's that's a good thing at a personal
level
but as as a matter of society as a
matter of civil government
you simply cannot let that persist
order will totally dissolve anarchy will
be loosed on the world
it will totally distort our culture more
so than it even
has been you know even some members of
the mainstream media are aware of this
even people like don lemon on cnn
they're unrepentant nancy pelosi didn't
apologize for her tweet
where she indicted the whole country is
bigoted and believed jesse smallett's
lie hook line and sinker
but she did slowly take it down and now
don lemon on cnn is trying to change the
story
he's trying to say that cnn was no they
never what are you talking about they
never suggested
that the jesse smallett story should be
believed immediately
here's don lemon trying to rewrite
history you know it's been um
interesting trying to report on this
particular story and we've done several
reports on this show just
the facts straight here's what we know
here's what we don't know
because you don't want to get into a
place where
you are um you're just sort of
speculating about things
right and we don't know what happened a
lot of the media did that in politics
too a lot of the media if you
if you look at every single report on
this show it'll show you that it was
just straight
no cnn was just all facts right except
they weren't and newsbusters pointed
this out
newsbusters out of the media research
center great resource
they showed that don lemon's colleague
brooke baldwin reacted with
horror to the story bought it hook line
and sinker
and by the way even just don lemon's
claim we didn't
we just reported the facts if cnn didn't
buy the story
then why did they give it so much air
time they
breathlessly talked about this jesse
smallett thing
for days and days well if they said well
we're gonna hold our fire here
why didn't they hold their fire because
obviously they were creating the
narrative and perpetuating the narrative
that he should be believed that he was
right
that he was telling the truth and that
america's a bigoted place
that's all it was when the jesse
smallett story came out
if you look back at the archives of my
show i didn't cover it
now why didn't i cover it because it
wasn't news no because it would have
been irresponsible to cover it at that
time
i didn't want to jump the gun and say
that the guy was a hoaxer even though i
knew with 99 certainty that this was a
hoax
because chicago is not mega country
but it would have been irresponsible to
do it what cnn did was act irresponsibly
what
nancy pelosi did was act irresponsibly
and
now they're trying to rewrite history
okay hypocrisy is the tribute that vice
pays to virtue
perhaps we should be happy at least that
they're trying to rewrite history now
rather than double down i think some
other people are doubling down and being
completely uh
acquiescent to jesse smalling i think
it's actually better to do what the
media are doing
not take responsibility lie about how
you covered it but at least say
this was wrong this is terrible this
guy's got to be punished for it
we have to take a lesson from a social
level from a
level of government society crime has to
be punished
we have lost this sense entirely
we don't punish any of our criminal
criminals anymore
both parties are giving into this this
is from a moral
failure a crack up of our ethical
discourse
that makes us not understand what the
words criminal or the words justice mean
and people on the right need to hear it
just as much as people on the left
but when the people on the left
get this stuff wrong it's much more
hilarious because the left
is so so misunderstands
a reality this is one of my favorite uh
stories in the news today we have to get
to it before the mailbag
so you know that i'm in south bend
indiana right now i'm outside of notre
dame i'm going to be giving a speech
tonight
at notre dame because the university at
notre dame
has these beautiful 18th century murals
from uh luigi gregory he was a vatican
portraitist
beautiful murals of christopher columbus
and the university now up up to and
including the university president
father jenkins
has decided they're going to cover up
all of the murals so that nobody can see
them
they're not they they can't move them
because they're painted on the wall so
they'd have to go full taliban
and just knock the whole walls down and
destroy art entirely
so what they're going to do is just
cover it up so that nobody can see them
and this hatred against christopher
columbus is based not only on moral
idiocy
but on historical ignorance they don't
know what christopher columbus did they
accused him of things he never did
they accused him of things that other
people did they don't understand the
significance of columbus in history
they have no gratitude for what he did
and how they stand on his shoulders
the shoulder of that giant and think
that they are they don't realize that
they're dwarfs
they think that they're just giant
people themselves
and this ignorant activist has reared
its ugly head
again in north carolina where vandals
have destroyed a statue
of general lee but not that generally
they destroyed these guys went out and
destroyed a statue
of general william c lee who was a
soldier in world war ii he's considered
the father of the airborne
and these idiots thought that it was a
statue of general robert e lee
and they thought that it would be right
to destroy that statue so now they went
after this poor guy from world war ii
here is mark johnson who's the curator
of the william c lee airborne museum
in dunn north carolina explaining the
vandalism
this is a hometown grown boy here that
turned out to be an international hero
in world war ii so to come and try to
destroy his statue
it's just an insult to everybody i think
it was a big mistake
why would you do something like this
really just to irritate people at you
this is not a civil war museum and this
is not
robert e lee this is general william c
lee so i was hurt
yeah sorry guys you got it wrong by a
century
you were off by 80 years what did they
do someone doused
the statue in a flammable liquid they
set it on fire
by the way we've been talking about
genealogy a little bit recently
because i found i'm very likely a direct
male descendant albeit a bastard
of henry viii uh jet william
seeley has no relation whatsoever to
robert e lee
there is no connection there's no
philosophical connection no historical
connection a family connection
completely different people and this is
what the left does
all the time this is why they attack
christopher columbus
a little learning is a dangerous thing
they've been told
they've been programmed by their
re-educators by the people who have
indoctrinated them
columbus bad columbus genocide
columbus mean columbus bad
and so they just they go beep beep boop
beep boop columbus bad
beep beep beep boop bop bop bop burn
down statue
boop bop beep hate history hate art
beep boop load taliban program beep bop
beep beep
and that's what they do and then they
set statues on fire but they get it
completely wrong
they don't even it obviously would be
indefensible even to set a
statue of robert e lee on fire that's
also indefensible
but it's both indefensible and
hilariously stupid
is it a statue of william c lee on fire
this is what happens when you don't know
history when you have no humility
and when you are frequently wrong but
never in doubt this is what happens
when you have no sense of veneration
when all you have
is intellectual pride the sense that
anything that happened before me
is bad and wrong anybody who lived
before me is stupid and wicked
i alone in my beautiful enlightened
modernity
am the only person who has ever seen
with clarity the moral landscape
and everything else will be knocked down
covered up with tarp or set on fire
we'll be covering this tonight at notre
dame
i sure hope that we're allowed to stream
the speech
i sure hope that there are no
shenanigans that go on at notre dame
uh so hopefully you'll be able to watch
it at daily wire if you're around south
bend i sure hope that you can make it
out there
i told you there has been some
shenanigans uh antifa
has threatened to come and protest so it
it might be lively gear up for anything
tonight but i will be making a robust
defense of art history liberal education
and in particular one of the greatest
men in history christopher columbus we
gotta get to the mailbag but first
go over to dailywire.com it is ten bucks
a month one hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me you get the
andrew clavin show you get the bench of
piro show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
which is coming up you get to ask
questions in the conversation
we had that yesterday ben's is going to
be next month you get to ask questions
backstage
you get another kingdom you get
everything but do you know what you
really
you get the leftist tears tumbler i
actually do fear
for my safety tonight i do think that
i'm in a bit of danger
because i've been on the road you know
tsa screening and you got to minimize
everything you travel with
so i'm on the road and i'm just here
with this
i just have this little plastic
coffee cup that i'm drinking my coffee
out of
i left my leftist tears tumbler in los
angeles
and looking at the rsvps from antifa
tonight
from the the university's reaction the
administrators
all the people who don't know anything
about columbus but hate columbus
i might drown i'm not afraid of antifa
clocking me i'm not afraid
of the university censoring me i'm
afraid of drowning
don't let this happen to you go get your
leftist years tumblr
we'll be right back with the mailbag
from judy hey michael is this a good
opportunity jesse smallett's false
attack for our sports players to let go
of the disrespect for the american flag
and the people who have sacrificed to
give us freedom
seems like much not all of recent acts
of racism and homophobia are false
but widely believed due to the
dissemination on the part of the media
an astute and excellent observation and
yes this is what we would call a
teachable moment
because so much of the
hatred the wild anti-westerners
anti-americanism that we see all around
us
is based not even on
people's skewed moral landscapes though
that's part of it
but on just flat out historical
falsehoods
if the mainstream left-wing narrative
about america were true
then america would be a pretty terrible
place wouldn't it
if america were a country that were
founded
simply to benefit one
minority group of people defined by
their physical characteristics not at
all based on ideas
not at all based on a transcendent moral
order not at all based on liberty
or self-government or veneration
or our tradition that has allowed so
many freedoms
so much equality such justice if it were
just
based on an illusion on deception
on slavery and misery
yeah this would be a terrible place
wouldn't it if america was
responsible for all of the misery around
the world
instead of as it really is responsible
for
greater alleviation of that misery than
any other political force in history
if that were if it were really that bad
then it would be a terrible place
and i think a lot of the idiots i i
don't like to call people names but i
don't know
let's just call them ignorances
in the national football league who are
kneeling for the flag
are doing so because they don't know
anything and it's not just that they
don't know anything it's that they know
so many things that aren't so
that's what mark twain said it's not
what you know that gets you in trouble
or
not what you don't know that gets you in
trouble it's what you know for sure
that isn't so and the left
the nfl players the antifa protesters
the administration of these
universities are
they just know for certain so many
things that aren't so
and i think if we could show them this
jesse smallett incident
and say look here you knew for sure
you believed as this guy said with pure
certainty
that he was attacked by these racist
bigots and half the country hates black
people and it's a bigoted place and it's
a dangerous place
that wasn't true and that is not true
it's a lie it's a lie being told by
cynical people trying to divide and
destroy the country and they're trying
to deceive you if we can take this
moment and just
shake some people say listen look it
isn't true
i know you still believe the narrative
but the narrative is being exposed is
false
that would go a long way and i think it
would correct a lot of this behavior
people find out that the narrative is
false the disrespect will likely fall
away
from daryl dear sir maddow
do you believe god can forgive suicide
thanks love the show fan in ireland
of course god can forgive whatever god
wants to forgive
suicide is a grave
and terrible evil it is an unqualified
evil it is horrific and it deserves
eternal punishment in hell dante
when he describes people who have
committed suicide
he puts them as the in hell having
cast off their bodies and at the
resurrection of the body
they will not get their bodies back
because they
cast it away there's actually a great
poem i'm going to look this up right now
this is a wonderful poem by a
by a formalist poet named a.m juster
and a.m juicer wrote this poem about uh
suicide that i just read the other day
it's a short poem and
it tells you everything you should know
the poem goes like this
no no not this time i cannot celebrate a
man's discarded life
and will not try these knee-jerk elegies
perpetuate the nightshade lies of plath
why glorify descent into a solipsistic
hell
stop softly curse the waist don't
elevate his suffering to genius
never tell me he will live on never call
it fate
attend the service mourn pray comfort
those he lacerated
keep him in your heart but use that
grief to teach
when you compose a line it is a message
not just art
be furious with me but i refuse to
praise him
no we have too much to lose we have too
much to lose
by embracing a culture of death by
saying suicide is okay
oh it's okay to end the suffering oh he
was
really just a tortured genius genie
you're free
as the academy tweeted out on the
suicide robin williams
that is horrific suicide is an
unqualified evil that said
people who commit suicide are often not
in a
stable state of mind they're not
thinking clearly they are not being
rational
and so it is perfectly legitimate to
pray for the salvation of people who
have committed suicide
i do it all the time friends who have
killed themselves
i i regularly pray for them and we can
have
hope of their salvation because
their being out of their right mind has
mitigates some of the moral gravity and
some of the
culpability for committing that grave
sin the sin remains
horrifically and unqualifiedly evil
but we can hope for the salvation of
those souls and we should be very clear
and very cautious and very
careful as we make that distinction from
brendan
mr coffee what is your view on marijuana
legalization
brendan i i don't care at all i do not
care
whatsoever i basically oppose marijuana
legalization even though i don't care if
people smoke pot
i've smoked pot on a number of occasions
in my life i don't really like it i've
always preferred tobacco and alcohol
more
but if that's your thing i doesn't
really know skin off my nose
however i really want to frustrate the
political ambitions of people who are
obsessed with legalizing drugs
first of all why would we what's what
good will be accomplished
by legalizing pot very few people go to
prison for simple possession
the people who go to posses to prison
for simple possession of pot
are people who have pled down because
they're drug dealers and peddlers of
poison
during the worst drug epidemic in our
nation's history certainly in modern
history
so i have no care about that sort of
thing
well a lot of people smoke pot okay
that's fine a lot of people do a lot of
illegal things
a lot of people speed does that mean we
shouldn't have a speed limit
i don't i don't think so well
but you know weed is really not any
worse than alcohol it's actually better
for you than alcohol yeah okay
fine alcohol is not good for you either
when you abuse it
but alcohol has been with our
civilization forever
christ's first miracle is turning water
into
very very good wine for people who have
been drunk already for several days
this has been around our civilization
forever why would we introduce
something new just doesn't make sense it
seems like
a further sign of an ev increasingly
decadent culture
and there's no reason to encourage that
sort of thing and also i'm not a
libertarian come on
grow up guys come on come on all right
we don't
i hey hey i'm a cool conservative i like
pot
they're not gonna like you okay stop
trying to be hip you're not hip
there's nothing hip about being
conservative
from uh jesse dear michael
what is your opinion on media that is
sacrilegious for example i've tried to
stay away from video games that involve
using things like angels as
enemies or jesus pretty much in any way
i just tend to err on the side of
caution and cut certain things out
but again curious your thoughts on the
matter thank you for your time
well one of the great modern
works the screwtape letters treats
angels
and god is the enemy the screwtape
letters by c.s lewis
is a demon writing to uh
to his nephew talking about how to
confound the enemy who is god
surely you wouldn't disapprove of screw
tape letters by c.s lewis
paradise lost treats hell as heaven and
heaven as hell
and the main character of paradise lost
is satan
surely you wouldn't call john milton
unacceptable media no what matters is
context
i if if a work of art is prevent
presenting
sacrilege or presenting blasphemy dante
presents blasphemy and sacrilege
if it's presenting it in
in a broader picture of a larger moral
universe or to make a point
that is anti-blasphemous then that's a
wonderful thing
but if it's just some video game where
you're gratuitously slaughtering angels
that's probably a bad thing
and i would stay away from that as well
as always what matters is the context
what matters is the
point of the art what matters is the
larger artistic realm
that is being portrayed and so i
wouldn't be surprised at all if some
video games are gratuitous wrong and you
should stay away from them
but don't stay away from lewis and john
milton from patrick
knowles can one person can a person
believe in god
and evolution without contradicting
themselves thanks
yes absolutely of course it was a
catholic priest who discovered the big
bang
uh i i don't see any i mean it depends
also what you mean by evolution
there are now so many competing and
contradicting
theories on how evolution takes place
we don't really have a good explanation
of how a species turns into another
species
there's not a ton of evidence for that
but there's
we certainly know that genetic mutations
take place and so
keeping an open mind to the various ways
in which
god has created the creation i mean that
just seems to make sense to me
and cynically citing parts of scripture
out of context as a way to
disprove some discovery of natural
science also seems
ridiculous to me as cardinal bronius
said the scripture tells us how to go to
heaven not how the heavens go
from michael michael i need your advice
i'm here to give
i'm a 28 year old former bartender and
will graduate this year with a degree in
poli-sci philosophy
i also live in a congressional district
where the current rep has been in office
for 22 years
my advice is about what i should do
after school i'm leaning toward law
school but i obviously meet the
requirements to run for congress what
should i do
thanks michael well i guess you could
move to queens and
then you you would become instantly the
congressional representative
28 year old bartender that's all you
need these days you could be the darling
of the democrat party but i don't think
you could be the darling of the
republican party
i'm very skeptical of
people who want to run for office the
second that they possibly can
without any life experience first i
think that's a bad idea i think it will
make you have a bad life
i i once was driving around with a
governor i won't say which governor i
won't put him on the spot but i was
driving around with a governor
on the campaign trail i was pretty young
at the time and he said so
you interested in politics and i said
well i'm driving around with you on the
campaign trail what do you think
he said well here's my advice don't run
for congress
don't do it i said well i'm a young
politically interested guy that's what
everybody wants to do he said do not do
it
you when you do it as a as a young man
you lose your
friends you're constantly just raising
money you don't stand for anything
you don't have any experience you don't
have any perspective and you leave
with nothing but a bad record because
every bill is designed
to make it look like you voted for some
terrible thing
that's just the nature of congress what
what is the point why do you want to run
for congress what do you want to do
what do you think you can accomplish in
congress if it's just that you want to
start your political career young
do something else first i'm not saying
don't run i think it's a perfectly
wonderful thing to run for office
for the right reasons but do something
else first law school is a good idea
law is a wonderful profession
but don't just run
to try to win a popularity contest or
something
if you really think that you can
accomplish something in congress as a 28
year old
with little experience from your
district okay i'd be willing to hear
that argument but you'd have to make a
pretty convincing case
that you can actually accomplish
something from
nalani hi michael a leftist tried to
argue that america is inherently racist
and pointed to the founding fathers
they claimed they were racist because
they owned slaves any help responding
lonnie yeah tell them that we kill a
million babies a year right now
and the entire culture basically seems
fine with it
obviously there's a major pro-life
movement
but there were abolitionists among the
founding fathers
there were many of the founding fathers
even those who weren't
outright abolitionists strongly
disapproved of slavery
in fact they had to reach many
compromises in writing the constitution
or the country never would have been
built
how will history look on us
a culture that slaughters a million
babies a year where
elected governors of states call for
babies to be killed
as they're being born or after they've
been born
outright post-birth infanticide
something tells me that the founding
fathers who
tolerated for a time the institution of
slavery will look
far more morally advanced than we will
all right last question from rodolfo
hi michael easy question i hope a lot of
my wife's family converted to some form
of christianity where they're forbidden
from
drinking alcohol and dancing or
listening to music other than religious
music
this seems really bizarre to me because
as far as i know there's no explicit
scripture
about engaging in these activities can
you explain where this comes from and
why it's incorrect
thanks came for ben's day for knowles i
don't know where it comes from because
it is incorrect
jesus as we just said christ's first
miracle was turning water into wine for
drunk people
good wine for people who had already
been drunk for several days because at
that time
the jewish wedding ceremonies went on
for for more than just three hours they
went on for days at a time
i don't see anywhere in scripture where
you're not allowed to dance or
or and i certainly don't see anywhere in
scripture where it tells you to listen
to modern religious music i'm pretty
sure that's a sin
actually because that music that
saccharine trash is so awful
that i think god is grimacing every time
you play one of those insipid stupid
hymns
you know on eagles wings or with the
acoustic guitars or
getting a drum kit in church good lord
go to go do some penance for that
go to confession what it comes from is
people looking at the profundity
of the christian tradition the
profundity of scripture looking down
as i've used this image before looking
down a deep dark well
but they've got blinders on they won't
use any
broader interpretive scheme they won't
take in the grand
thoughts of all of the great church
fathers the great doctors of the church
the great christian leaders spiritual
leaders thinkers in all of history
they just have their own narrow ideology
and so what happens is they look down
that well
and they see nothing but their own
reflection on the surface of the water
and so it's very easy for people who
have a prejudice against
or a bias against dancing or booze or
whatever
or good music and they have a bias
against that
so they say oh that's in scripture it's
not in scripture it's not in the
christian tradition
it's coming out of your own head that's
fine if you want to prevent your friends
and family from doing those fun things
i guess it's your prerogative but don't
try to put those words in god's mouth
they aren't there
okay that's our show i hope that you're
able to tune in tonight at notre dame
we'll have to see what happens
in the meantime i'm sure it'll be very
wild in any case and i'll be able to
update you tomorrow
till then i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
robert sterling executive producer
jeremy borin
senior producer jonathan haye our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens
edited by danny d'amico audio is mixed
by dylan case
hair and makeup is by jessua overa
production assistant
nick sheehan the michael knowles show is
a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019